it's not just Jen saki of course
election denier Hillary Clinton was on a
joy read
getting too old for this [ __ ] uh Hillary
Clinton on Joy Reid uh and uh well
January 6 blah blah blah so I want to
away from
with Paul Pelosi and broaden it out
because what we have with the rhetoric
coming from the Republican candidates
from their party right now is so
disturbing I didn't see a big outpouring
on the part of elected officials to
stand with Nancy Pelosi the way she has
stood with Republicans as well as
Democrats in times of real terror like
on January the 6th
it's so disingenuous it's remarkable and
I just want to say as someone making fun
of Hillary Clinton right now I did not
kill myself I have no intentions of
killing myself I did not kill myself and
let's just keep the uh the cameras on
all the time
um
Nancy Pelosi when Steve scalise was shot
up by a Bernie supporter
um were the Democrats all running around
uh saying nice things no of course they
weren't we've shown you many compilation
videos Maxine Waters and the rest of
them get in their faces AOC the point of
protest is to make people uncomfortable
also if you keep calling people white
supremacists and Nazis do you think that
your base might do some crazy things
about people look nobody's hands are
totally clean here I'm not going to sit
here and tell you that every Republican
has done everything right of course not
uh but but the the the level of her
thorough dishonesty is just incredible
but that should not surprise us because
Hillary Clinton as you know is an
election denier Senator Ted Cruz who was
here on the show when we pressed him uh
on the Maga Republicans election denial
he did whip out some sort of prop and he
argued that your mother did the same
thing
um I do think that he knows uh that uh
he's an illegitimate president
I'm pretty sure that I remembered that
next day I was standing behind her when
she conceded yes he's an illegitimate
president and that she said while she
had campaigned very hard against
President Trump uh she hoped that he
would be a president for all Americans
illegitimate president you know I think
that Senator Cruz just might have a
slightly different memory of that
I do think that he knows uh that uh he's
an illegitimate president
yeah you guys got it you got it by the
way when Sonny Hosten who is just you
know my feelings about Sonny Hassan when
he whipped out Ted Cruz he whipped out
some sort of problem some sort of prop
it was a it was a piece of paper that he
had in his pocket that went through all
of the times that Democrats had denied
elections and Democrats had done things
violent but they were completely rude
and dismissive to him